good morning super thrilled to be here
actually over the last 20 years I've
basically lived a pretty entrepreneurial
life I was born in the former Soviet
Union which I will bring up as a theme
here because I think has a lot to do
with the way I think about HR and people
and where the world is going
I immigrated to the US when I was three
years old we lived in a studio apartment
the size of the stage that I'm on with
eight family members so very humble
beginnings my my American dream my
family's American dreams started when my
dad got a job as a stock boy for two
bucks an hour in a liquor store and
eventually you know how many people here
are immigrants or children of immigrants
great so a lot of you know the secret
which is don't spend any money on any
dumb [ __ ] for a decade save it and buy
something which is very much what my dad
did he bought a small liquor store in
Springfield New Jersey you know I am an
early investor in Facebook and Twitter I
built a 60 million dollar liquor store
when I finally got into my dad's
business very quickly on the back of
email marketing and Google AdWords and
innovation
I appreciate the intro I have
showmanship DNA and a lot of energy I am
a pure bred entrepreneur as a DNF
student and gave up on school and fourth
grade so clearly something in my DNA and
definitely in the way that my mom
parented me I've always had enough
confidence and thinking to myself and
within myself and not being worried
about what people talk outside of it
I've got all these things but ironically
for me for the hundreds if not probably
a thousand speeches I've now given in
the last decade I've probably been more
excited to be here today than anything
or any other place I've ever been and
here's why couple things number one the
biggest single investment cheque sighs
I've ever made in my entire career is in
a company called haikyuu
which is in predictive big data analyze
ation of people's retention within
organizations right I
have built my latest company from a 0 to
150 million dollar revenue business in
the last seven years and I've spent the
first five and a half of it being more
the head of HR than being the CEO it's
even more fun literally the phone call I
was on just now before I came out here
for twenty two minutes literally hanging
up one minute before I took the stage
was 98 percent and HR conversation with
a key executive I am confused and this
is actually even better now as I'm
talking the fact that this conference is
this subject matter and is in this city
and I'm sure quite a bit of the content
that you'll be hearing will be more tech
based more AI based more big data based
more CRM based more sass based it's
insane to me how excited I am about the
future of the world because as
technology
Kumada Keiser's [ __ ] that doesn't matter
all of us are going to be forced into
the things that actually do matter which
is people the punchline is I actually
suck at almost everything hard skill
wise you know in hindsight I can't read
and clearly dyslexic I just haven't been
you know you know analyzed that way I am
terrible at everything other than
intuition empathy gratitude EQ it's
actually all I've got and what's really
crazy to me is that the emotional
intelligence and the people aspect and
when you're great at it and when you
define HR the way I do it's funny I've
been an entrepreneur to only have owned
my own businesses I didn't realize until
building an agency like I have in the
last couple years hiring people that
have worked other places I actually
didn't know this is not a joke this is
back to being very narrow I didn't even
realize that the HR brand was a negative
I thought it was a positive I'm a very
yes-man oriented operator so because I
micromanage HR and my two companies the
wine business and vaynermedia and I
would always basically just say yes like
if you wanted more money if you wanted
to change something to me it was all
offense see an incredible thing
is not talked about in the world which
is we will all sit here as professionals
or people of interest in this world but
the fact of the matter is 99% of
businesses are CFO biggest 99% of
businesses care about dollars and cents
and so what they do is they make
decisions in ninety day terms not in
ninety year terms I stand up here as
somebody that's obsessed with HR
obsessed with people look at it as a
financial offense because I believe in
retention and continuity which then is a
gateway to speed which is an advantage
when you compete against any other
business speed is the ROI it is the
differentiator in sports and in business
speed is what matters and continuity and
having people stay in a place for a long
time leads to speed but even more
importantly the thing that leads to
speed and execution is when our
employees don't have to sit at their
desk and think about politics and dumb
[ __ ] and actually think about the work
and the reality is all of this
appreciate it cause that's the punchline
right I'll take that clap thank you bro
it's just true it's staggering how much
percentage of every single employee in
the world right this second is thinking
about how to navigate through the
political matrix versus getting the
actual work done and so for me I'm
agnostic I'm unemotional I could care
less how you're trying to achieve this
whether it is through tech or products
or services but I'll tell you how I
think about it at vaynermedia it took me
a long time to hire the person to really
run our HR we don't call it HR we call
it the pet team it stands for people and
experiences her name is Claude silver
she's our chief heart officer I believe
in branding and positioning once I
discovered that HR maybe didn't have the
best branding I wanted to make it very
black and white of how I thought about
it she on the org chart sits ahead of my
CEO oh and my CFO she's the second most
important person in my company she
leaves with her heart
when there is a debate between emotion
continuity what's best for the internal
vibe versus the CFO this hurts our pl we
will not hit our numbers she wins
ninety-nine out of a hundred times and
just how we think about the world and so
for me you can talk about all the
commodity programming that I genuinely
believe will dictate this conference and
this conversation I think the more
important question is what are your
organization's actually doing about it
and if you're the sweetest person on
earth and you really give a [ __ ] but
your company at the top doesn't allow
you to make the actual decisions based
on the right thing in a five-year macro
versus a five-minute micro because
numbers are going to get hit you're not
going to get anything accomplished
you can think ideologically all you want
everything stems from what the engine
and the finish line is within this
organization and so for me what I'm
fascinated by is actually how many
people in here are a CFO raise your hand
perfect [ __ ] this is going great
I'm serious actually so for me I think
you guys are actually going to like
where I'm going with this I mean I think
this may be a curveball of a Content
conversation but let me tell you where
I'm going with this I think I think this
conference next year needs a hundred
fifty CFOs
in the audience let me explain I don't
think about HR and people and all of
this warm and fuzzy stuff of how I think
about myself because I think a mother
Teresa or the nicest guy that ever
walked the earth I think of it because
I'm an assassin entrepreneur who's
trying to buy the New York Jets and I
think it's financially viable to
actually give a [ __ ] about people I
think when you actually have a black and
white conversation with a CFO that Karen
Rick the CFO of this company actually
could understand why what HR is supposed
to be doing which is retention and
happiness you know the only thing I
think about in my company have 750
employees the only thing I care about is
on a one-to-one basis what drives them
and what do they care about in life and
by the way these cliche [ __ ]
headlines like Millennials care about
this or general it's so ludicrous the
amount of 25 year olds that I have in my
office right now who'd rather work 19
hours a day if I just pay them $1,000
more because the only thing they give a
[ __ ] about is a thousand dollars more or
the amount of 52 year olds that care far
more about work/life balance right now
because for him he just went through
this thing in his family that makes him
want to work a little bit less these
headlines these generalizations are the
death are the death of organizations the
only tech that you should give a [ __ ]
about is the one that gives you the most
data on an individual basis for every
single person that works for you that is
in real-time because I don't care what
you told me a month ago about what's
important to you if what's important to
you today has changed I need to have the
nimbleness within my organization to
adjust to that reality and again and me
make this perfectly clear because I sit
up here truly believing that my HR
skills far more than my marketing skills
or salesmanship skills have been the
defining foundation to why I've been
able to build big businesses I sit here
and remind everybody the reason I want
150 CFO's in this audience next year is
because I want to suffocate suffocate
this conversation to them so that they
understand this is financially viable
that when you make a decision in a 90
day window that is financially ugly to
them in their [ __ ] excel sheet that
the trickle-down economics of that
decision make their financial sheet look
really pretty in a 24 month window this
is financially practical there is
nothing that can be said or talked about
at this conference that matters anything
other than do you fundamentally
understand what every single employee in
your
Asians cares about in life right this
second there are 17 meetings going on in
my company right now that sound like the
following hey blank karen is trying to
ruin me or I really hate Rick or I'm
being suppressed or my favorite you know
I love middle management
they're either arguing that they don't
have somebody above them that's giving
them mentorship or they're arguing and
complaining that somebody above them is
micromanaging them like they're just
complaining right and so that is
happening at scale that is the biggest
action within my organization and we
spend ninety four ninety five percent of
our time on things that have nothing to
do with salary or hiring or firing or
promoting in our engagements within our
organization and it's scales and it
works and it will be and let me remind
everybody in here when when everybody
talks about whatever they're going to
talk about at this conference
specifically I'm sure augmented you know
animated all these things that are going
to take out jobs and all these things
that are coming at a macro that are so
much further away than we realize
because we love to think something's
happening tomorrow when it's happening
in 15 years when that's all being talked
about please understand what it means of
course over a 50 year macro yes there
will be jobs that are eliminated guess
what
that's always happened it's not as good
to be a farmer as it used to be back in
the 1300s being a Mason was a really
good [ __ ] idea right like everything
gets wiped out that's the punchline
that's so what you need to be focusing
on for everybody here as an impact in
the next twenty to thirty years of your
career what you need to recognize is
that hard skills and information
continue to be commoditized what you
need to wrap your head around is what
the way I've run my organizations which
is the people that are best at their
jobs are far more often fired because
they're not as good on the emotional
intelligence side the way I frame up my
company is called the honey Empire right
honey / vinegar first then Empire then
you have to be best at what you do and
why I do that
is not because it sounds good it's
because hard skills and talent continues
to be continues and this is true it
continues to be commoditized by
technology it is far easier for
technology to attack IQ information and
certain skills that is able to attack
the emotional intelligence the GRA the
thing that has never and will never be
replaced
which is a human operating system of
these emotions so the energy that I'm
most passionate to bring to this
audience today is are we having the
right macro conversation are we going to
spend a lot of time talking about
crossing the T's and dotting the eyes in
here are we going to talk about all the
[ __ ] semantics that we love to pander
that are just so disproportionately
secondary to the punch line which is I
can give you the greatest [ __ ] HR fast
tools of all time if you don't actually
give a [ __ ] about people or you're not
in a place where you financially have
the ability to make a judgment call once
you decide it and give a book about
people it doesn't matter what tool you
have and that's it honestly I really
have nothing else to [ __ ] say I'll
try to fill up my time
and you look fun and that was super
important for me and I'm so thankful you
guys just gave me that I'll tell you why
that's the punchline and you guys know
it right like like that reaction that
clapping that was for nothing other than
you acknowledging the truth we all know
it so to me to me as I the way I think
about speaking it's very much the way I
think about running an organization
it's just 5149 it's just my job to give
my employees 51% of the value of the
relationship
it creates stickiness I know what to do
with my 49% it's why I've had a good
speaking career I don't come up here for
anything else then how do I bring you
the most possible value in my half an
hour that you actually leave with
something and when I think about this
group of people people that I probably
admire the most in the professional
landscape if you actually give a [ __ ]
about it right I think to myself let's
just have the real conversation like
it's far more ROI positive for what
you're trying to achieve in your
organization or your life if you use my
energy in this 30 minutes as the
catalyst to push you over the edge to go
back home and have the real conversation
than any tactic I'm going to give you
I'll give you tactics let me tell you
what I do it's insane that every company
doesn't follow every action and every
word out of every single one of their
employees minds and thoughts on social
media I have a better indicator on
everything about my employees because of
social then I do buy anything what do
you think is happening in resumes it 316
reviews are the biggest [ __ ]
horseshit of all time the [ __ ] is a 360
review you mean another human being
giving feedback on somebody completely
and utterly predicated on their vested
interest you mean we have not figured
out as a world yet that everybody
usually has a landing spot and once they
get there they go on complete defense
and they will tear down everything
around them that creates a vulnerability
for somebody taking their spot
have we not figured this out so so we
are doing tactics to appease ourselves
and the best people in this room know
they're completely [ __ ] and so my
question is so what
because you know you're part of the
problem if you're just walking and going
through it and not believing in it I
look at you the same way I look at
marketing executives everyday that are
pouring money into TV and print and
radio they don't believe in it they just
know their organization accepts it and
then they're just living I know that the
far majority of you are doing things
within organizations that you don't
believe in you're just doing them
because they're the way the machine has
been set up and so then I asked you are
you any different than the people that
you're judging that are doing the same
within that organization I stand here in
front of you today to be very frank to
get one [ __ ] person in here to have
the bravery to have the real
conversation which is you either make
and run your organization on short-term
financial decisions or you don't and
when you don't an amazing thing happens
you start having air cover to making
human decisions you have the ability to
actually start making decisions that
think about the impact of that person
has on culture in a 36-month macro not
on how much revenue they're bringing in
tomorrow the best teams and sports value
people that play their role the amount
of people I have in my organization that
are average energy I have 40 people I'm
40 to 60 people in my company right now
that are pretty average at what they do
for their skill but what they bring in
an atmosphere in positivity and optimism
in another year to be that somebody goes
to if they are scared to come to me or
my pet team what they bring to the macro
is so overwhelmingly positive it makes
the entire engine roll and that is a CFO
conversation not an HR conversation hey
[ __ ] CFO Steve here may be okay and
cost 83,000 dollars
but pay attention he's impacting this
$417,000 of salary that's driving 4.9
million in top-line revenue you can't
have these arguments with a business
around feelings you need to have these
arguments with business around money
with feelings being the engine of how
got there do you understand that's how
you get it done and so look I don't
expect most of you to step into the [ __ ]
that my HR team has which is their CFO
and dictator is obsessed with legacy is
obsessed with long-term finances if it
has a situation where the board or
investors have no [ __ ] say and it is
what it is and he actually really gives
a [ __ ] way more about you than the CFO
that's just awesome right the worst job
on earth is my CFO job poor Alan right
that's just not what you guys are
dealing with so the reason I invested in
haikyuu
big data analyzing retention it's just
math based which gets to the finance
base which then gives you the air cover
you're right you're just fighting the
fight with the wrong weapons you're
right you're just fighting the fight
with the wrong weapons use that energy
of what you believe creates retention
continuity culture and vibe and
translate it into money and I promise
then you will have people's attention
that's how you get it done that's just
the truth that's the world we live in
small business corporate startup
everybody it's why the VC world and
startup world here in San Francisco is
so broken nobody's building businesses
they're building financial arbitrage
machines to get funding though these are
not real businesses they're running on
metrics I actually ironically think
that's how most of your businesses are
they're not building great businesses
because they're making financial
decisions day by day while you're
deciding and fighting on the gray the EQ
the emotional center the culture the
continuity and that is the disconnect
and I implore you to start translating
into their talk if they have final say
my CFO has ironically started figuring
out how to use math and money to talk
about culture and EQ to get what he
wants and it's been fascinating to watch
him figure out oh [ __ ]
Gary doesn't even open the Excel sheets
he Calise is over when we talk about
bottom-line profit margin but when I
talk about Karen's feelings he actually
looks me in the face so I'm the reverse
and you just have to figure out the
reverse and that's the punchline so
to talk about and I have no idea of like
you go out in the floor there and they
tell you how great it's going to be and
like how this tool is going to save you
this that the other thing doesn't
[ __ ] matter it just doesn't what
matters is are you actually in the
mindset of bringing more value to your
employee than you ask in return because
you realize that at a macro you get what
you want out of that so other tactics I
am this is just now I'm going into some
random [ __ ] I've been forcing a lot more
of my leaders to really really start
spending a lot more time on these three
to twelve person dinners and breakfasts
and it's just really been working for us
been thinking a lot more tactics of how
to create colliding cultures I just it's
so fascinating to me how basic what we
do for a living is it's just
communication and FaceTime but it's
imperative
the reason it's working for us is I'm
suffocating and forcing them to speak
the truths not the things that they're
just saying and saying things on the
back make sure that you're not creating
a culture where there is a place for
people to hide their true feelings in a
box versus addressing them get people
uncomfortable with cut that are
uncomfortable with confrontation but
come from a good place try to think
about creating safe environments outside
the office for these conversations I
don't know if you guys have budget to do
things but I would tell you that as I've
hacked over the last 20 years more micro
events have been bringing me far more
value than macro events you know you
take a whole department in an off-site
you know and then all of you know this
the smaller you can make the group the
more likely it's all fear right the
smaller you can make the group the more
likely you can get them into the actual
conversation so I I've been spending a
lot of time on these four or five six
person dinners I've got another one this
is completely left-field random when we
fire somebody and they disagree with
that with me really it's not us me I've
been pushing them very aggressively to
meet to leave negative
views about my company on Glassdoor I've
got a pretty interesting concept I don't
know if this falls into your guy's world
I've been pretty aggressively asking
people who disagree with me to air out
their grievances on Glassdoor because I
think it's ROI positive for an
organization to eliminate anybody
applying for their company that actually
believes in anonymous reviews I'm being
serious I really think this is an
interesting one right like there's
literally people that work at companies
that we fake positive reviews which is
so ludicrous because if somebody lacks
the emotional intelligence to understand
who would leave an anonymous review
that's negative on a site you don't want
that person in any way and so we've
noticed as we pushed down our rating on
Glassdoor the quality of our employees
has been better not worse so that's just
a little curveball that I'm sure I'm
going to assume not a lot of people are
talking about and it's probably not the
standard best practices but I'm a huge
fan of it um I don't know I've said my
piece let me have a question do have two
minutes they may have a question yep
I'll repeat it for you sure question is
can I expand on what knowledge we're
getting about our employees from social
media
who else they're hanging out with in the
organization so who are their real
friends right their interest graph so
you guys know this right
Jason Loomis has been with me for five
and a half years three years ago four
years ago I realized he was a humongous
st. Louis Cardinals fan right he was
really doing a good job and so I bought
him two tickets to a Cardinals game and
flew him out to st. Louis and it cost me
seven hundred and thirteen dollars and
it probably saved me fifty thousand
dollars in the last 40 years of giving
him bigger raises
you know and and by the way I'm not
advocating underpaying people I'm
advocating the binary thought that money
and title are the only things that
people trade on is stupid
stupid at best and completely [ __ ]
tone-deaf to reality at worse so we use
social to understand everything about
them are they taking a ton of selfies
with with um you know going fishing you
know we give presents on everybody's
yearly anniversary when you give
somebody a present
that's a fishing lure versus a [ __ ]
$25 Amazon gift card you actually are
speaking to giving a [ __ ] versus
checking the [ __ ] box and other
things right like like I think it's
powerful when you take your engagement
photo right you're super excited right
you're the ring it's [ __ ] always so
nice it's a [ __ ] beach and all this
[ __ ]
I think it's powerful for my employee
who still hasn't spent five minutes with
me who's worked for me for seven months
that when she posts her engagement photo
that I see em the first person to
comment and say congrats [ __ ] matters I
just I just think it's all [ __ ] up
right we have unlimited vacation policy
best thing ever
we did it for we have unlimited vacation
policy you'll love this unlimited
vacation policy I look at it after two
years you always have to check your own
[ __ ]
I look at after ten years two years I'm
like [ __ ] nobody's taking vacations
people act on fear so because it was
unlimited 40 percent them like [ __ ] that
I'm not gonna go at all because that was
a [ __ ] okay so then we made it two weeks
mandatory but back to honey Empire my
company's not honey rainbows and flowers
it's honey Empire we have unlimited
vacation policy but it's probably a bad
strategy if you're just average to have
already taken 29 days of vacation at
this point this year somebody in my
company right so so I was born in the
Soviet Union I'll leave with this I was
born in the Soviet Union let me
the difference between communism and
capitalism in communism you put people
in a box and they play within it in
capitalism we give people freedom and
when you do something wrong we put you
in a box
it is flabbergasting to me that all of
your companies in a capitalistic
environment are putting people in a box
I know more about my organization thank
you I know more about my organization
because of unlimited vacation policy and
safety and culture because it's how I
get an indicator at a macro because when
you give people unlimited rope you
actually figure out who they are versus
what all of you are dealing with which
is people are navigating through the
system you created and you actually have
no real feel for who they are thank you
[Applause]
[Music]